that's why you want to be good that's
why you want to be fair to yourself
because any injustice is done only to
yourself as the quran says so you're
only doing injustice to yourself
you're bringing this on to yourself
every negative thing that ever happened
to you is brought on to you by yourself
so
in my opinion islam is talking to you
from
a position of pure
reason if you were purely logical
you would ask the same question rene
descartes you would ask
how do you know you're not dreaming you
know one
one uh
chinese sage once said i read this a
long time ago i haven't studied eastern
philosophy but he says i don't know if
i'm a man dreaming i'm a butterfly or a
butterfly dreaming i'm a man
if you're a purely logic
a logical person all you know
is you're going from one world to the
next and this one seems this one that
you wake up and seems to have continuity
however when you're in a dream it also
has continuity you feel like let's see i
don't know let's say you dream you're a
professor well you didn't just appear
that day you feel like you were always a
professor in that dream
so to speak
hence
when we speak in small circles when when
logicians are in small circles and
they're talking they're like look how
can we tell how could we decipher from
one experience and the other the truth
is we cannot we only do it on sheer
blind faith this is a very important
point
we only do it on sheer
blind animalistic
faith
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
that's crazy because
y'all know how like impactful it was
yeah isn't it if you're watching this it
was so it was such a strong dream
that i woke up
and then i was talking to my dad and i
was crying
because how strong the dream was how
impactful the dream was
and then i ended up driving to uh the
mosque it was like 5 40 something
to do fajr at the mosque and i was
crying the entire way to the mosque
and subhanallah i think it's crazy that
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims we're joined
here with a very special guest today
brother faraz zahabi salaam alaikum
alaikum salaam
so how's it going man alhamdulillah very
good
how about alhamdulillah good good so uh
tell me what you trained today
what did i train today mm-hmm today some
mma striking with wrestling and then
after that some jiu jitsu with the
jude's class or wrestling in jiu jitsu
from 11
till about 2 30. so it was quite quite a
workout today
[Music]
all right all right so we're going to
start with a quick rapid question let's
assume you're in a room right now with
an atheist all right and you have to
convince this guy that god exists
and you have anywhere from two to five
minutes all right so what would you say
go
well
there's i'm not honestly i'm not in the
conversion business you know i just tell
people what i believe what i think how i
got there and if they see it the way i
do fine if they don't see it the way i
do i ask them to show me you know why
not now i also have to tell you i don't
believe in atheism i don't believe
atheists exist i don't believe they're
actually any atheist i believe that all
human beings in their heart of hearts
they believe in one god i believe you're
born with the fitra and you cannot
escape it okay so this is my position
and i believe it's the islamic position
to be to be you know completely honest
uh after studying ghazali and various
philosophers from islam i really believe
that
this is the heart of islam islam is a
natural religion and also a revealed
religion so there's nobody who's truly a
a real authentic atheist the reason for
that is
i always like to give the example of
a blind man if you talk to a blind man
and you ask him about the color red
no matter how intelligent he is he has
no idea what you're talking about
to him the color red is just a sound he
believes you because other people tell
him that they can see
and that he's missing out on a certain
perception
and he has that leap of faith he says
look this is not a huge conspiracy
people are telling me i have a handicap
i'm blind and they're seeing these
colors and i'm not
and they can prove it to me they can
call out an object that's on its way
towards me and when it arrives it's
close to me like check out the object we
told you it was coming your way we saw
it with this perception you have you do
not have you do not have this perception
so when i talk to a blind man about the
color red he has no idea what i'm
talking about
because he's never experienced the color
red
i've never spoken to an atheist talk to
him about god he's like what are you
talking about i've never heard of this i
have no conception of it whatsoever
because you can understand my concept of
god you haven't you have had a direct
experience with this
idea god so for instance if i see red i
have a direct experience with red
and i've never seen a red bicycle in my
life
but if you talk to me if you show me a
black bicycle a green bicycle and you
say remember that color red you saw yeah
imagine a red bicycle we should paint
this bicycle red
now it might be the first red bicycle in
existence
but i can imagine it why i've
experienced red and i've experienced
bicycle and now i can put them together
okay
you cannot talk about the color red
unless you have experienced the color
red you know i don't know if you guys
have kids but i told my kids don't touch
this is hot don't touch it he has no
understanding until he touches it and he
burns his hand and then he realizes now
i understand what you're saying when you
say it's hot
all kids burn themselves eventually why
they have no idea what you're talking
about when you tell them something is
hot
you're just making a sound with your
with your with your mouth that they
don't they have no association with it
after they burn themselves say oh that
word hot ass is associated now with that
pain
when i talk about god and you converse
with me
you tell me you don't believe it
you're you're in a way you're admitting
you're admitting you have this idea
within you
now imagine
imagine you were in a
in a dark room your entire life you were
in a dark room your entire life you
never were exposed to a flower you've
never seen a flower you're just sitting
in the room your whole life we've
incubated you in this room and one day i
open the door and i show you a flower
now you have the idea of flower in your
mind now guys i'm i'm uh drawing on many
philosophers over the years i'm kind of
like putting it in the nutshell okay now
that you've seen flower for the first
time we can talk about flowers
if i came into that room and you never
saw a flower and i started talking to
you about flowers you have no idea have
no experience with flowers
you have no idea what i'm talking about
unless you have some sort of experience
that's similar to flowers i can't even
describe you what a flower is you won't
understand
how come when i talk to people about god
they always tell me yeah well i don't
believe in god because if this if god
was so good he would have removed all
the pain but you're conversing with me
you're talking to me about you
understand what i mean by god
khalas in my opinion you have a belief
in god deep in your heart of hearts you
have a belief in god you know that's
what the the word kaffir originates from
somebody who's covering
what is he covering he's covering his
fitrah
but deep down inside he's not atheist
deep down inside in his heart of hearts
he is not atheistic now i'll tell you
that
you know god even before you were born
why do we say that well if you think
about you know if you try to reverse
your life back if you play your life
backwards there was a time in place
where you're in the womb
and you didn't have an ego yet you know
psychologists say the ego develops at
the year of one eight at the year of at
the age of one years old
then you develop an ego you have that me
there's the world and there's me before
that you have no duality
you feel that there's just existence you
don't have an idea of who i am there's
no fear zahabi i've had nobody told me
my name i don't know that i'm i'm i'm
separate from the world i have no such
experience i'm in the womb i have no
experience with the dunya the outside
world i haven't tasted
uh honey yet i haven't felt cold or warm
i don't know the difference i haven't
had any real experience
now this is very very early on in
existence in that time all you know is
this oneness of existence
you have this oneness there's no
competing
data
there's no dunya and there's no me
there's no me there's no
there's no uh separation let's say it's
just this experience of oneness and
islam in my opinion is to go back
and if you reach the highest levels of
islam it's to go back to that one level
and that that one level that one
experience is best um
it's best expressed
by the words
when you see everything as metaphor and
only allah is objectively true we can
talk about that also later
islam is
the realization that only god exists
objectively everything else according to
gazelli okay because i have to appeal to
authority here because nobody's going to
believe me who am i
everything is metaphor
everything me and you we're all metaphor
we don't exist the same way as god god
exists
objectively and uniquely and in one
sense we are
we are just a reflection so for instance
uh the famous uh ayat in the quran
and it talks about god is a light and
the lamp is a reflection of that light
ghazali appeals to that he says look the
every human being is a point of
awareness
would you say that every human being has
a has a point of awareness within him
this point of awareness within you it's
not part of the dunya you know we call
it consciousness we call it uh you know
uh the soul we call it there's something
within us that we all experience
that we don't observe in the dunya
you don't see it a lot of times some
philosophers refer to it as the beetle
in the box okay so um
i'll give you a quick example then uh
i'll let you guys jump in okay
when you saw a dog for the first time
somebody pointed at that dog and said
that's a dog we made the sound dog
pointed at it now you associate that
sound with that animal
if i show you enough dogs you're like
hey every time he says dog i see a
four-legged fuzzy creature with teeth
and eyes and there's various sorts of
dogs and the word dog
refers to this object in the world and
you do that for every object if i show
you an orange okay i show you multiple
oranges when i make that sound orange
you associate it with the citrus
orange
delicious sweet fruit
and you learn every object like this
however when we talk about the soul or
the consciousness
we're never pointing in the dunya
we're saying look look within you
there's this thing that i cannot even if
i opened your brain and i opened up your
brain i looked inside i wouldn't see it
this thing escapes the dunya
it's the light if you want to call it
or the heart as razzali says but
he says not the lump of flesh in your
chest he's not talking about that
that one thing within you
that when i talk about it you know what
i'm talking about
but i've never pointed to it nobody's
ever cut the brain open found where it
is took it held it in his hand it's only
known directly the taste
now this is a reflection of allah's
existence
we are a reflection of allah's existence
we're shadows
and allah he exists
objectively now we got to talk about
what is subjective and what is objective
there is nothing i challenge anybody to
bring me something in the dunya that is
100 perfectly objective
they will never be able to philosophers
we can punch a hole we'll always find
some level of subjectivity
except with one thing
except with the one thing that's why i
can't when you tell me oh this guy's an
atheist he's not an atheist so my
opinion he's not an atheist
he's not there's no atheist in the world
there's no atheist there's no human
being who hasn't known
the fitra
so i would say okay maybe he's careful
he's covering it he's in denial but i
don't believe he's truly atheist
um
i agree bro that's why they're known as
disbelievers and not unbelievers
you see the crown doesn't really talk
about atheism
yeah
and uh i mean
if you look at i that's why one of my
the most influential thinkers
that i appreciate the most is razer
because
he took this deep dive to try to really
understand islam at the deepest deepest
levels
and islam is and i i
really feel that muslims shouldn't shy
away from this islam is a spiritual
awakening it should be a spiritual
awakening a spiritual
a spiritual
experience now i'm not talking about
falling on the floor and shaking and
speaking you know i'm not talking about
this kind of things
but it's a private person everybody has
their own private personal experience
direct experience
to god
what does it say in the quran allah is
closer to you than your jugular vein
what's closer to you than your jugular
vein
allah you have a direct personal
experience to god and that's every human
being there is no human being that was
left out
so
i don't really believe in atheists they
don't believe in my god i don't believe
in that they don't believe in my god so
we're still made and i love to debate
them but i don't try to convince them
because in my opinion
it's their personal choice
whether they
whether they admit to themselves or not
and i love how the quran puts it when
they're on the ship and the waves come
they all become believers when they're
hanging in the balance all of a sudden
all the fitra is so clear and so so true
and so obvious they revert back to their
primordial selves you cannot escape it
me i just give them time and i really
feel like it's a lot of times our fault
that a lot of people are atheists the
muslims the christians the jews
we give a bad name to religion why
um we do so much of the opposite of our
religion teaches us we're supposed to be
the most just the most patient the most
friendly the most spiritual the most
loving
but we don't live up to it so people
disassociate with organized religion
because they see so many
politicized uh positions or motivations
people use religion for politics
or they use religion for their own
personal gain and that obviously it's
gonna turn people off you know so i
really believe islam is about finding
your
innate
uh natural religion rediscovering it
that's why the quran calls itself the
reminder what's it reminding you of
it's reminding you of what you already
know
see in in
in judaism they have the they call it
the beni the beni noah those who survive
the ark they stay true to the fitra they
call the fitra those of the benino the
the tribe that survive the ones that
stay true us we call it the fitra
the christians
they say that no religion is a based on
a historical event
they say if jesus died
and rose from the dead christianity is
true and you're saved if you believe it
if he didn't rise from the dead if this
historical event did not happen
listen this is very important
because they took our our
natural religion and made it about
history
they said look this event happened 2000
years ago i'm going to prove it to you
and when i prove it to you if you don't
believe in it you go to hell if you
believe in it you go to paradise you go
to heaven
but
even the assassination of jfk we're
still not sure what happened we had
cameras
we have microphones we have countless
eyewitnesses we have experts
scrutinizing the footage what happened
retracing it we're still not sure if
there were two shooters
three bullets we're still not sure of so
many things and that was a modern day
historical event
we're still not sure what caused
who pulled the trigger and how
imagine that you're asking me to prove
something that happened 2000 years ago
where the evidence came out 40 50 years
later and never seen an eyewitness we've
never had
primary source material nobody that was
on the ground ever left any
documentation for us to study
you're asking me now to base a religion
on a historical event
that's why islam if you look at islam
it's telling you anybody who believes
that says this or that it's all
guesswork they're full of doubt
and in the quran it says it says to
muhammad ali it says you weren't it
tells them about the story of noah about
the story of moses you wouldn't know
this unless we informed you your
religion is not based on you retracing
the footsteps of moses per se yes we
believe in moses by way of authority the
quran says moses is true we believe in
moses yes for certain what i'm saying is
i don't have to go back and prove moses
it's not what our religion's about our
religion is about the fitra
yes we believe in it but we're not
sending you back in time we're not
asking you to be the world's greatest
detective
we're asking you to look inside and
recognize that you are born with the
idea of one god and the quran says
something also very beautiful when it
promises you the afterlife the next life
it asks you to think about how you got
to this life
according to all these atheistic
philosophers atheistic scientists
this
existence shouldn't be
it's impossible that we're having this
conversation it would be if i if i
brought them before the huma first human
beings and i just showed them chemistry
and physics
you know uh uh heavenly bodies colliding
with each other
and somehow we can have this
conversation in a parallel world and
observe this world and i say look
there's gonna be this thing called life
that's going to emerge no impossible
there is no life it's just chemistry and
physics
now life has happened obviously we're
living it directly and they still want
to deny that life is going to happen
again
so
just to put it really simply i remember
my son he was crying uh because his
grandfather died his great-grandfather
died and he was crying and asked him why
he was crying he said oh i'm never gonna
see him again and i asked him why he
says that why does he believe he'll
never see his grandfather again say oh
he's dead i asked him one simple
question how did you meet him the first
time
how you met him the first time you're
going to meet him again say in sha allah
like allah brought you in this world is
going to bring you into the next
world how you you can't understand well
look where you are right now
the miracle happened of life and
inshallah it'll happen again and
nobody's logic is so great and believe
me i'm uh i'm a i'm a lover of logic
okay
nobody's logic is so great they have
understood how life works i don't care
who you are
nobody's logic is so great
what we have to do is observe what is
happening
we can't explain it but it is happening
allah says god says in the quran it says
when the do you see the grass die allah
sends a rain and the grass is revived
that's how allah is going to bring you
back again yes you will die
but you used to be dead
you used to be non-existent if you want
to use the word non-existent used to be
something other than alive
then you came to life
by how
try to explain it interesting theories
but they're all weak at some point
they're all weak and doubtable
in the end we lived it
we know that life comes to be
and some people say oh no but it's going
to end forever how the hell do you how
do you know this
how do you know this
when the it's
it's incredibly
glaringly obvious that new life always
comes there's always new life
people are born every day people are
coming from another another place of
non-existence a place of non-existence
people are being born all the time
people are coming things are coming to
life all the things are dying and coming
to life all the time
so for me i just observe what's
happening around me and i say oh it
happened again in the future and this is
what the quran tells you to do look
around you
isn't death and life a cycle
so i have great uh faith that like i've
met my children in this world i'll meet
them again in another world inshallah
yo this this is amazing thus far
that's powerful the the book that you're
talking about from imam gazelli is it a
alchemy of happiness
i'll keep my happiness is really good
books autobiography it's very very good
but i really like the work of frank
griffel he wrote the philosophy of
razzali he kind of gives a great
summation and the footnotes are amazing
they kind of send you off at different
paths to find different sources that's
really the work i always tell you if you
want to study ghazali read frank griffel
why read frank griffin number one he
authenticized
he checked the authenticity of different
letters that were written by razali and
two ghazali and
he actually uh
went out and
and
studied the scrolls themselves some
things were never even copied from
ghazali the man did a phenomenal job of
bringing what has ali said to life
authenticating it and reaching the most
uh authentic sources
and gazelles work is amazing i feel that
frank gerfel
did an incredible job of bringing it to
life frank griffel for those who spell
his last name
it's g-r-i i think f-f-e-l
okay just circulated
i switched it up it's frank grissol
g-r-i-s-t-o-e
mm-hmm you know griffin
give me one second
he's the head of uh islamic studies at
the department of religious studies in
yale university
incredible uh book really honestly
an incredible book he put some fantastic
uh
sorry guys i'm just trying to turn this
off here he did an incredible body of
work he authentic hey authentic
authenticized
um the work
it's it's such a such a brilliant book
amazing and from there i think you can
spring board into hazard's other works
and hazel is not easy to understand
because he's actually very open about
not saying it directly he doesn't
believe in saying
uh giving his position away directly
[Music]
i actually had a friend
who he was on a podcast with me
separate from this one and he told me
about mama
he put me on to the first book which was
just the first chapter of the alchemy of
happiness which was on knowing yourself
in god
man masha'allah that that took me four
months to complete but four months
because i had to really take my time and
like
just understand everything that he was
putting out there but it's
i you know i studied i studied
philosophy for about
10 15 years before i started reading
geselli's work and i'm happy i did
because i would not have had an easy
time trying to understand what he says
um
he's his his work is extremely profound
he had an incredible understanding of
epistemology which was
really um amazing but i feel like it's
not an easy place to start
it's not an easy place to start like he
says things without giving you a
background he reminds me of a lot of
emanuel kant like it's almost like he's
writing to professional philosophers
you'd have to be
almost like you'd have to study for 10
15 years before you really even
understand some of the things he says
like i'll give you guys a for instance
okay
um this is i call it the abrahamic
experience i think it's a crucial
position for all muslims to understand
it's so important you know people ask me
why don't you believe in thor why don't
you believe in zeus why don't you
believe why why do you believe in this
one god
why not believe in the plethora of gods
and there's a very simple quranic answer
to this it's a very very simple quranic
answer
now picture picture the idea of uh santa
claus none of us here believe in santa
claus obviously
just made up right
but we believe in man we believe in
reindeer and we believe in flying these
are all things you've experienced when
you were young you saw a bird fly in the
air you had the idea now in your in your
mind about flying
you had no experience with flying before
you had no idea of the
of about the idea of flying until you
saw a bird fly in the air and of course
you
met other people there were men and you
saw a reindeer one day in the zoo or on
in a book on tv now you have the idea of
reindeer you can mix all those three
together and make up something that's
compounded as we say in philosophy you
compound it you took two ideas and you
mix them together so for instance
i can you know people say oh yeah why
don't you just believe in the spaghetti
monster
the spaghetti monster is a collage of
ideas it's like multiple ideas coming
together so for instance if i have the
idea of god in my mind and i have the
idea of war i can make the god of war
you understand if
i have the idea of man and have the idea
of marshmallow i can make marshmallow
man now when you compound things even
one of the most stern atheists
david he will admit to this he says when
you compound things those things may or
may not exist however
things that are in your mind
were once in your senses so for instance
if you if you know the taste of honey is
because once upon a if you could think
of the taste of honey once upon a time
honey touched your tongue it had to go
through the senses
if you know the color red like we talked
about earlier if you can imagine the
color red it's because your eyes once
upon a time red went through your eyes
it went in the senses nothing went
nothing went in the mind that wasn't in
the senses john locke would tell you
so
until you burn yourself you can never
know you can never think about the pain
of burning yourself
it has to be first in the senses and
then you can have it in the mind once
you have it in the mind then you could
do all sorts of collages i love how uh
rene descartes puts it he says look
no matter what you draw on a piece of
paper it's never original it's always
things you saw in the world and you mix
them together he goes if you me if you
inve if you picture a man with a glass
head
a bubble head a glove made of glass
that's because you you've experienced
you've seen men in the world and then
you've experienced glass and you said
what if i mix in my mind the idea of a
man with a glass head
there are no such men in the world
there's no men out there walking around
with a glass head
but you can't deny that there is glass
and there are human beings
everything you compound bring together
i'll give you a famous example one more
just to make it simple
david hume says oh what about a golden
mountain
you saw a mountain in the world you saw
gold
one day you saw a gold chain or
something like that and then you decided
to imagine up a golden mountain imagine
there was a golden mountain in the world
golden mountains don't exist
this is what the quran is telling you is
like don't believe in the pagan gods the
pagan gods are people taking what they
lust for
and
mixing it with the idea of god
so you love war i pray to the god of war
oh you love thunder because it's
powerful and it's majestic ah zeus is a
god of thunder
you're mixing ideas you can make up a
crocodile god you can make up the
spaghetti you can make things up i'm not
about making things up i'm about
seeing what's inside my mind and tracing
back where each idea came from
we're taking inventory
we're taking out every idea where did
this idea come from how could it be in
my mind how did it get there
now
john locke the way he described it is
you're born as a tabula rasa you're born
as a white sheet of paper okay
or a blank canvas if you will
and then you're born in this world and
you have experiences you feel heat okay
so now we're going to draw on the blank
caves he experienced heat
okay he experienced i don't know um
the taste of something sweet okay so now
he knows about sweetness
oh he experienced the the sound of a car
driving by okay now he knows the
rumblings of an engine
and we list all the things you've
experienced now all these experiences or
we're listing them we're listing them
and they become every day there's new
experiences and he can mix and match
them in his mind in different ways you
can imagine new things you can imagine a
flying carpet now he saw a bird fly he
saw a carpet
flying carpet
but a philosopher knows what's imaginary
and what is that went through the senses
now
emmanuel kant famously asked
okay there's this tabular raza this
blank sheet of paper
and all these experiences are happening
but can't ask where did this tabula rasa
come from
this blank sheet of paper
this point of awareness what is this
awareness and again this is mentioned in
the quran by the way
who
god says who gave you hearing and seeing
you have this awareness you are aware
in the you are aware
of the dunya
a rock
is also chemistry in physics
like me i'm chemistry in physics
but that rock has to my to my
understanding has no awareness of the
dunya around it the world around it
we have this awareness that's why i
always tell people think of yourself as
a point of awareness
and then
remove the idea of being a point
you know hazeli describes when you say
allahu akbar like when you pray when you
say but he's talking about
that the significance of that movement
is you're taking the dunya and you're
throwing it behind you
now you have to remember even the body
is dunya
worldly thing for those who don't speak
arabic it's a worldly thing when you're
when you're in your salah you should
there should be no nothing else in your
mind
but allah but god
you're trying to go back to that oneness
that you existed because don't forget
even your ego is dunya we told you your
name is so-and-so
it's all
construct social construct
everything that's not allah is dunya
when you do allahu akbar you're supposed
to chuck the whole world behind you
you're supposed to be like
when you are in the earliest
stages of existence
unknown unknown who you are what you
what you are even even the you even the
me has to be chucked even me is dunya
there should be nothing left you should
go back to that
blank sheet of paper once again
and then you're going to have a direct
experience of god
[Music]
it's heavy
if you read the quran it's always about
dunya and
so there's something on my mind that uh
i wanted to know what is your personal
journey to islam uh for a lot of born
muslims i consider them reverts not in
the sense that you know they came on to
islam um you know out of birth but they
came onto it on their own accord later
in their life so what was your journey
like was it
was it like holding on to it like a hot
coal growing up in or at least being
here in the west or was it something
that you always held on to uh well no i
was i was very westernized when i was
young super westernized um learned very
little about islam early on but all the
things i learned about islam early on
because my dad did bring a chef to kind
of talk to us when we were kids
and i realized that a lot of the things
that he taught us was the the things
that gave me success in life
like uh
you know like
he always taught me that you have to see
good in everything
god is the wisest nothing bad ever truly
happens to you it's only a fitnah it's a
challenge how are you going to react
these things made me in my opinion
helped me become very successful
and i didn't have many uh negative
feelings i had very positive feelings it
was when a challenge would happen i was
like oh that's a fitna
i'm going to get past it there's going
to be something good in it
there's a head there's something
positive in there i just don't see it
now i have this faith that something
good is going to come from this
and you know just that attitude and you
know he used to teach us that you know
the quran it says you're never going to
have a test greater than what you can
pass
now when you're young you know you you
believe that
it makes you extremely powerful strong
in your mind
because when challenges come and people
tell you it's impossible you're like
well it can't be impossible because i
wouldn't have this test if it was
impossible that's where my mind was very
young so they nurtured my mind very
young
to never quit to never see
uh to never despair
and i could think i honestly think that
i would have never been successful if i
was not uh molded in that way at a young
age because i didn't have any critical
thinking they just kind of
they just kind of encouraged me and sent
me out into the world
and i always had a deep deep belief in
god
because it was oh my it was my
religious beliefs that always gave me
success you know i could have quit a
long time ago i could have
i could have uh
been intimidated and not never went down
certain paths i went down
and
but it gave me that courage and that
ability to try and never give up and i
find that that's such a powerful recipe
for success
yeah go for it bro
it's been very very real so far
masha'allah yeah good i'm happy
oh my god
okay happy i'm waiting for you
sorry guys my daughter she doesn't do
she doesn't read so she's gonna have to
uh
no i know i know
[Music]
i have one of my sons coming home from
school and i gotta have him pick up my
daughter at the bus stop
she's gonna double check
take your time norris
you guys know what full metal alchemist
is
yeah i do you know for us is like the uh
the muslim alchemist
this is amazing stuff by the way
thank you brother
you know i really wish um
more muslims would uh you know you know
this is all in the quran i mean if you
read the the there's a there's a verse
in the quran about abraham
where he says oh i believe that this the
moon is my my god then the stars and
then he says oh it's the sun
he realized that he's mixing the idea of
god with all these deities because the
pagans worship the moon stars and sun
and one greater than the next and he
realized no no god is one and if you
read the passages carefully it's telling
you this is this is that's why i called
the abrahamic
abrahamic experience because this is
part of our religion what does the quran
say it says tell the christians and the
jews that abraham was on the path before
the scripture
what does that mean we were muslim
before scripture came before you heard
about
this or that that happened in history we
were already muslim
abraham alaihissalam was already muslim
adam alaihissalam was already muslim
islam came before the scriptures
hence it's a not in inborn religion
it's a naturally born religion yeah it's
amazing because i feel like even more
evidence towards this fact that it's
something that we're just born with
is all the examples you gave were based
on observation you observe you observe
you combine right
but
and this goes back to what you said
before about allah being objective and
all of us being subjective right
you know allah says in surah allah in
the definition of allah
is the one who doesn't need anything
from anyone but everything depends on
him
if you look at the end of it
there's nothing even comparable to allah
say that again translated
like nothing there's nothing like unto
him there is nothing there is nothing
like him
yeah he is unique in class
yeah there is no other there is nobody
shares in this objectivity nobody shares
in this level of existence yeah hence we
are all metaphor
we are all metaphor
you know you guys ever hear of the ship
of thesis
no
okay so ship of thesis is this guy his
name is thesis
okay
and he has a ship now i'm going to give
you guys my variation of it he has a
ship the ship has 99 parts
every day he takes the ship out every
day there's one part that needs
replacement
now he's traveling back and forth with
this ship for months and months every
day is replacing a new piece after 99
days 99 pieces have been replaced
and every day he goes in the market and
he fish and he goes for to to fish and
he everybody sees him riding on his ship
and everybody's like this is thesis and
his ship we see him every day we know
him well
and every day has to change a piece
after 99 days all the original parts are
in a warehouse somewhere and he has new
parts and he's still going up and down
the sea with that ship
then one day i come about and i take
those 99 original parts and i rebuild
the ship
but he's still going out every day to
the market
and fishing with his ship
his ship
now we have two ships and ask you guys
which one is the ship of thesis which
one is the original
one of them he's on it every day and the
other one was the original parts
there is no objective answer
the ship of theseus is a metaphor in the
mind
the ship of thesis is a metaphor in the
mind there are just 99 pieces here and
99 pieces there
so 198 pieces
you projected it from your mind that
this and that is labeled ship a thesis
there is no actual ship of thesis out
there in the world
there's no objective ship of thesis
similarly
how the ship of thesis metaphor your
body is metaphor your body the cells are
changed every day some cells are changed
within the first seven to ten years of
your life every single cell in your
body's changed yet we still call you by
your name
so that's why we tell he is well i'm not
the body my body's changed throughout
time
i've changed all the parts yet you still
call me by the same name you still
consider me to be the same life form
same timeline of existence
but ever if i'm just physics and
chemistry how come now that every single
element of my physics and chemistry has
changed
and you still refer to me by the same
name i'm more than my physical body
you know uh what's his name the famous
atheist hitchens said i don't have a
body i am a body
it's a very interesting comment he's
saying all i am there's nothing more to
me than this
flesh and bones
i am a body
well then i love how uh
john lennox responds it says well why
didn't he survive his own death because
when he died
his body's still there it's out there
was a point where he died and he's 100
of his body's still there
it's not just the body he's something
else too because we can we cannot point
to him and say he's dead
wow where's the body's still there why
why is he
how do you become dead if there's
nothing else
the fact that i can point to a dead body
and a life body the fact that there's a
difference between them that means
there's something else other than the
body however the problem with them is
they're so
and bring me any any atheist philosopher
or scientist you want on this channel
i'll have a discussion with them happily
how come they can tell the difference if
all you are is a body
there has to be an element
that's different now they're going to
say oh well one is functioning one is
not
each functioning body has a
consciousness
but because i can't turn it to phys phys
physics and chemistry because it's
beyond
physics and chemistry they automatically
say it doesn't exist
but by saying that it doesn't exist
they're referring to it
which ironically proves that it exists
how does he know what i'm talking about
i've never i've never
pointed to anything in the universe and
said look that there's consciousness
right there consciousness is only known
perfect by by first-hand experience by
you by you admitting
to cuts to understanding what what i
mean by consciousness you've you've
accepted consciousness like for instance
i'll give you a a an as maybe a simpler
example to understand that that uh
um
what's his name philosopher uh
cyril uh professor searle says he says
look
could you imagine a zombie
a dead person walking around he's dead
but he has no soul
we can all imagine zombies okay well
that proves the soul exists because you
the fact that you could imagine me minus
something there is something there for
you to minus
so
uh john cyril says look just the fact
that you could imagine zombies proves
that there's something more than just
the body because what is if there's
nothing more than the body what are you
what do you what are you deducting what
are you what are you taking out
the soul exists the mind exists
consciousness exists but it's known
directly we know it via
first person experience
and this my friends is the most certain
thing
we know
because you know ibm tamiya will tell
you look
there's there's
there's scientific knowledge you know
science knowledge of the senses you know
experimentation
you know something sweet you have to
taste it to know if something is hot you
have to touch it okay there's empirical
evidence then there's logic well
empirical evidence can be wrong
because your senses can be lying to you
we could talk about that later but this
is without beyond the shadow of without
true like for instance the smartest man
in history at one point he was at that
time the smartest man in history
aristotle saw the sun go around the
earth he thought the sun goes around the
earth why his eyes were telling him but
it was an optical illusion it's not the
sun that goes around the earth it's
earth it goes around the sun but he
believed that the sun goes around the
earth why he observed it and everybody
around him observed it and it made sense
to them
your your senses could be
misleading you in many many ways
and what about logic well show me two
logicians from their time that actually
agree
aristotle didn't agree with plato
galileo didn't agree with aristotle
leibniz didn't agree with sir isaac
newton uh even to our modern day and age
chopin howard didn't agree with
heisenberg they both don't agree
even to me is asking whose logic are we
going to use who's such the who's the
greatest
whose logic is so perfect we can rely on
it so
if
empiricism doesn't bring us to certainty
logic doesn't bring us to certainty
because your logic could always be
fallible
you could always make an error and we
have
an abundance of proof in philosophy that
logic could be mistaken i'll give you
guys a great example later
what are we going to use to know to be
certain
well you know he says look god made it
so easy you can't be wrong
god gave you
the fitra and you know it first hand you
don't have to use logic you don't have
to use a scientific experiment you have
to go out in the dunya and find uh
something that happened 2000 years ago
or you have to see god through this
through the clouds this is not how you
get to god you know god through direct
experience you know him personally
everybody has their personal experience
with god in the quran it says everywhere
you look you'll see the face of allah if
you chuck the dunya behind you
if you chuck everything in the dunya
behind you where is there left
allah says when all has perished there
will remain the face of allah
the muslim is supposed to do this in his
lifetime hence
the hadith the
of the prophet
says die before you die
when you die the dunya is gone
allah says when all has perished there
will remain the face of allah
when you chuck everything truly when
you've let go of the dunya truly
and this is what's about practicing
letting go of the dunya when you say
allahu akbar you're supposed to chuck
everything you're not supposed to think
or feel or sense anything
but this point of awareness it's a
practice you get good at it the more you
practice the more aware you become of
allah
and the less the dunya is impressive to
you
the more certain you have you've had
this experience the more connection you
have with this eternal experience the
more certain you are of the
more certain you are
that
that
you have a direct experience of god and
the more certain you are of your faith
till you're 100 certain
let's say you have a new reaver who's
finally coming on dean and learning
about the basics starting to pray
what's your top advice to give this
individual to increase their mind
well
it's tough you know because i would say
that
religion now is
facing new challenges
religion is constantly bombarded
and criticized
and
ridiculed and looked down upon and put
in an unfavorable light
so you have to give them a kernel
of
experience
you have to give them an experience
that's so powerful
that no amount of ridicule like i often
ask myself would i still be muslim if i
was the last muslim on earth if you
don't answer yes to that question i
don't really believe you have a strong
faith
if everybody in the world left islam i'm
telling you i would still be muslim
why because i've had this internal
experience
that supersedes all the rituals now the
rituals are important
don't get me wrong they're paramount
they're important
but if you're praying mechanically
if all your
chronic recitation is mechanical
if it doesn't go further than the throat
so to speak
then your relationship with god is very
superficial
and that's the the biggest of tragedies
so
what is the experience that makes you
reach a level while you would never
consider
disbelieving in god
because in my my position i doubt
everything i doubt even
who i am but i don't doubt god the god
is the only thing i have i'm look i i
say i say i believe many things
but i only know one thing
no is like i can't be wrong
i say i know god exists
i don't know any anything else it's all
belief it's all belief in faith and it's
you know in the quran it says believe
this believe that it says know this
know about allah you know allah
you know god god is another level
god is the ultimate level of certainty
god calls himself al-haq god is the
truth everything else my friends is to
some degree true or false there is no
absolute truth outside of god god is the
only glaring 100 percent true even one
plus one equals two i can doubt it even
one plus one believe me i can we can do
it in philosophy we can bring a doubt to
one plus one we don't know if
mathematics is actually referring to
something out there in the world
is it all just mental gymnastics
mathematics
we have these doubts we have these
discussions but one thing i cannot doubt
one thing i cannot doubt
is i love how avicenna put it there is
existence
i don't have to point to it i just know
it
it's self-evident as we say in
philosophy it's self-evident it's
glaringly self-evident
more so than a triangle having three
points or three sides
something that is considered
analytically true can't be doubted to a
certain extent
but it's still some kind of it's still
happening within my mind it's still it
still has some limitations in terms of
its definition and scope
so to answer your question you have to
that's why salah is so powerful because
if you're doing salat mechanically it's
kind of tough to do every day all day
long
but if it's a practice
about letting go of the dunya
then that muslim in my opinion he's
never going to uh lose his faith
if it's a practice of connecting you
know salah comes from the word connect
to connect
what are you connecting to this fitra
within me there's no there's no way you
could you can
you can
you can give me the most powerful
syllogisms you can run the most
scientific experience i don't care what
you do you can never shake my fit that i
might fit as unshakable i don't care how
many i don't care if tomorrow they prove
evolution to be true then my mind that's
how allah made the world
and we could talk about that as well
also because you know what does it mean
they can they can only prove it to be
true to a certain extent
but even then to me it would mean that
allah made the world this way
i'm sure of one thing everything else is
up to interpretation everything else is
uh i it's beyond my understanding so i
look this is the best i understand it
this is allah is not asking god doesn't
ask you to become the world's most
logical human being to know him now it's
good to be logical there's over 300
verses that praise logic and push us to
being logical don't get me wrong logic
is fantastic
you can never let go of logic we're
married to logic
however
the shahadah
is
for the ultimate doubter so the person
who doubts doubt that's everything and
at one point he reaches a point where he
cannot doubt
because this even doubting that would
prove this
this is what if you look at islam islam
is
there are no gods islam is the
closest thing to atheism atheism and
islam are very close islam destroyed
what did prophet muhammad alaihis
he destroyed all the pagan
gods
there's one god you cannot destroy
there's one left you we doubted them all
we died we don't believe in this one
this one has no proof these are all your
wishful thinking we're the most
atheistic
however we realize
through the fitra
wait there's this one last
you can't grasp it you can't doubt it
when you try to doubt it it proves it
and it has to do with existence
every time you try to doubt existence
well you know what your doubt is proof
of existence you've reached this point
where
you see this one shining
entity of existence
that always was
always was will ever always be
it encompasses everything and nothing
encompasses it
and it is defined exactly as is
described in the quran and it is al-haq
it is the only thing that is true
but it's surpassed
scientific data a scientific
scrutiny or empirical knowledge i should
say excuse me empirical knowledge or
logical
syllogisms it's beyond logical syllogism
we call we say it's transcended it's
it's transcended all our ways of knowing
things however it is at the same time
undeniable and in our face all the time
so if somebody has the connection with
this they can there's nothing that could
shake your faith nothing
there's just really nothing
what's crazy is that there are some
people who are in this atheistic state
right
and then they start to realize we just
said
that there is
something else you know that this isn't
all that there is and then they get
stumped on this idea that they are god
that's laughable
well we'll see when they get sick and
die and slowly die from cancer and they
have you know stage four cancer and
they're crippled and we say you think
you're god you think you're god you know
where is your god where are you now if
you're god where how come you're so weak
as a kitten if you're a god
you have to understand our hearts not
the lump of flesh as far as he says
are a mirror
to the one existing god
so the it's the ultimate
it is the ultimate
egotistical thing to say is that i am
god that's the most
ultimate
level of arrogance
we are observing god
what did the prophet sallam say why did
allah create the dunya allah was a
treasure that loved to be known
allah was a treasure
that loved to be known
we are here to experience
god
not to be distracted by the dunya
now there's listen i challenge any
atheist in the world
to find me a third option a third option
there are only two options
there's believing in god
and i recommend you go to the natural
religion
discover it
or the only other path
is nihilism
i don't know if you guys are familiar
with nihilism and nihilism my friends
is hell
there is no other paths there are two
paths
and you have free will to choose either
one
but there is no third path
if somebody out there believes there is
a third path bring it to me i would love
to see it there is no other third path
there is god or nihilism
hence
you are in this dunya to choose
if an atheist tells me i choose nihilism
i believe personally that at the last
moment he's going to flip 180
when he realizes what he's chosen
he's gonna crumble psychologically
when death comes close to him he's gonna
revert so quickly
when he has a realization this
realization
when he comes to understand that's why i
tell people about nihilism you want to
get an atheist out of atheism understand
nihilism and present it to him it will
drive him mad after a while because
there
you know they say ignorance is bliss
yeah if you're an ignorant person and
you don't you didn't think about it
but trust me that ignorance is only it's
only superficial one day it's gonna slap
you even the most ignorant person is
eventually gonna become face to face
with nihilism
unless you get blindsided by a bus and
you didn't see your death coming well
then you know
allah is going to decide what happens to
you but
as he always does but
if you're faced with nihilism and you
understand
nihilism truly understand nihilism i
think it's only ego that stops you from
believing in god it's the hatred of
traditional religions oh i'd have to
admit these guys are right but i despise
this group i have a cultural
dislike for them hence i'm going to
refuse to uh believe in god
i think it comes down to that the
friction comes from them not wanting to
associate
with characters in the past that gave
religion a very very bad name and there
are many and i understand about that i'm
sympathetic to them i tell them look you
know
nobody gives islam a bad name more than
the muslims
that's the truth we should stop blaming
everybody look at ourselves first are
you the most fair person you've ever met
islam is about justice you know if you
have to put islam in a in a nutshell you
have to describe islam i would say oh
islam is about justice it's about what's
fair
maybe what we consider fair seven you
know like
the principles of islam is about being
just and fair if you're adjusted for a
person you have no harm coming to you
now the greatest injustice is tonight to
deny god in my opinion this is what i
understand it's to deny god so they're
creating an injustice but
are muslims giving islam a good name
they should be able to print as many bad
books about islam as they want but when
people meet muslims they should be like
hey those books those media it's all
it's all garbage that's what should
happen
so when muslims interact with the world
they should remember
to be the most fair the most kind the
most generous and the least in love with
the dunya from all the groups of people
and you you you give from what you love
you give to charity from what you love
the dunya
has to have no grip on you
and you have to do things because
for the for the love of god and because
allah loves these things and you love
these things because allah loves these
things
then they could write as much they can
do as many cartoons as they want they
can they can bash us in the media all
day long when people meet muslims are
like no muslims are my favorite people
but unfortunately muslims many of you
know certain not but certainly give us a
bad name
and it's a shame
that's true
so
real quick if you could
could you break down what does nihilism
mean because there's probably gonna be a
lot of people watching yeah yeah yeah
they have like a brief understanding
yeah oh hold on one second okay i'm just
gonna check on my daughter if she's in
the mornings we can go for this
check
so i really do want to talk about the mm
and all that yeah that's my that's what
i'm really trying to get it i got so
many questions when it comes to this
afternoon inshallah
that you can check out my son
you're at the bus stop
text me when you're in the house are you
in the house
okay text me when you're in the house
and i'm on the podcast still okay y'all
have you i'll see you soon
okay sorry about that guys
okay so yeah what is nihilism
well
nihilism is actually a very difficult
thing to explain though nietzsche did a
phenomenal job of presenting nihilism to
the world but it's just such a
man it's such an incredible topic
nihilism is if i can put it in a
nutshell it's
the understanding
that if god doesn't exist
then whatever happens in this world
doesn't matter
whether you live or
die whether your precious children die
or not
it's all irrelevant
there is no good or bad
there's no evil
there is no
happy or sad
it's all
utterly
meaningless
you will never exist again
and your existence is utterly
meaningless
this was all for nothing
actually it would have been better never
to exist at all because now that you saw
what you're missing out on
it's actually torturous
i wish i was never born i wish i was
always just
you know
the element elementary particles or
whatever and any any elementary
substance and i wish i never became this
complex body witness the potential of
this world
for happiness and love and and caring it
really the richness this world can it
can can offer and then have it snatched
away from me
and find out that
we are all utterly meaningless there is
nothing
that has value
this is a
a very difficult and unpleasant
thing to experience
it's a very difficult and pleasant thing
and what i just said doesn't do justice
to it okay sometimes it's referred to as
looking into the abyss
sometimes referred to as
looking into the abyss if you do a lot
of soul searching
and you're an atheist
you will in the end be tormented
now those who are not tormented that are
atheists they don't do so any soul
searching
but like you know you have some
celebrity atheist i believe in my heart
of martha i believe that they are
tortured deep down and they're looking
for a way out and they're just gonna
find one closed door after another
why because for thousands of years
atheists have tried to find some open
doors some escape hatch and all they
ever find
is a closed door there is only one door
there is only one way
you have to discover the fitra
and that is best expressed as
there is no deity other than allah we
can doubt them all you should doubt them
all
you should disbelieve in them all
and if you try to believe this believe
in god allah you will find
abundant proof
you will be unable to escape this one
god
so
nihilism is to never admit to that to
always see that the world is because you
know what if god does exist
okay
everything is going to be made just
because by definition god is just god is
good everything is you know i saw i saw
a really amazing uh
meme yesterday which which was posted by
one of my favorite uh channels uh i
think it's he calls it uh
theology vlog a convert from theology i
i love him you know i wrote him i wrote
him an email once saying i would love to
buy him a new mic like i would like to
buy him an expensive mic just so i can i
could send it to him every time he talks
in the mic i'm going to get some benefit
you know i offered he never replied to
me but i'm still that i still want to
buy him some expensive equipment because
i love his channel i feel like i would
love to invest in this channel somehow
somewhere do you have his number gosh no
i i don't know i'll pass it on to you oh
really it'll be great thank you i really
love his material and he had this one
meme you know colin powell recently he
died
and it's him get reaching to the gates
of heaven and i don't know if you guys
saw this meme but they're like all these
faces in the background and
the angel at the gate says oh we have
millions of iraqis they want to have a
word with you
just because you died doesn't mean you
escaped what you did
nothing you did in this world is is is
gone
everything you did every word you said
is still there
every action you have done
still exists somewhere it's accounted
for
when you die you think hitler escaped
because he killed himself no he has not
escaped
this world is a just world it's a fair
world
we believe in god so we have to believe
the world is just yeah when you die you
think you escaped no
no
those millions of iraqis my friend
they're still waiting for you on the
other side
now let me give you a little food for
thought for those who think this is
preposterous what i just said
if you're a pure logician
meaning you believe only you believe in
logic and know
nothing that is
regarding an emotion you're not you're
not believing in narratives you're
believing only in pure logic you're a
pure logician
well gazelle tells you well how do you
know you're not in a dream right now
there's no logical way to know that
you're not in a dream this is a question
that stood the test of time no
philosopher ever proved a way for us to
know
that you're not in a dream think about
for a moment when you're in a dream when
you're in the dream
every character in the dream seems real
to you and you feel at that moment that
this is reality
you don't know that you're a person in
your bed right now not in this moment
and it when you wake up it feels like oh
the dream was so short
it was such a you know maybe i drum for
20 minutes
however when you're in the dream
it feels like a lifetime
sorry one second guys unless she's small
so serious she doesn't see me she freaks
out
we'll wrap this up real quick and then
we can start the next one okay well
uh like so you'll cut that part out and
you just i'll just get back to uh the
part of the tree okay
so when you're in a dream
you can't tell the difference in the
dream this is what is telling you
descartes said the same thing many
philosophers
touched on this okay
how can we know when we're in a dream if
we're logically in a dream can you
decipher it somehow you cannot i don't
care what kind of weird dream you're
having it all makes sense to you in that
world at that time it's just as weird as
this world we're living in right now
if you're a pure logician all you know
is when you die
you go into another excuse me when you
sleep you go into another world
that's all the experiences you have and
what does what does the quran say when
when god is going to raise people from
the dead he's going to ask them how long
were you in the dunya
oh a day a day and a half
a small time
it's exactly how
when you you're when you're dreaming you
could have dreamt you were a young boy
who became a
doctor and you went to school for many
years
that's all just a blink of an eye that
happened
well the dunya this dunya is going to
seem like that again to us when we wake
up in the next world as a matter of fact
if you in the quran says every time you
sleep allah takes your soul where does
he take you he takes you to another
world all you know
in this world all you know is you're
traveling from one world to the next
that's actually all the proof you have
if you're truly a logician all the proof
you have
is that you wake up in one world and
then in another and then another and
then another and then another and you
have no idea how you got there and some
of these worlds are great and sometimes
they're nightmares
and you can wake up in a nightmarish
world and you can wake up in a
in a heavenly world a paradise world
so that's why you want to be good that's
why you want to be fair to yourself
because any injustice is done only to
yourself as the quran says you're only
doing injustice to yourself
you're bringing this on to yourself
every negative thing that ever happened
to you is brought on to you by your self
so
in my opinion islam is talking to you
from
a position of pure
reason if you were purely logical
you would ask the same question rene
descartes you would ask the same
question hazali asked how do you know
you're not dreaming you know one one uh
chinese sage once said i read this a
long time ago i haven't studied eastern
philosophy but he says i don't know if
i'm a man dreaming i'm a butterfly or a
butterfly dreaming i'm a man
if you're a purely logic
a logical person all you know
is you're going from one world to the
next and this one seems this one that
you wake up and seems to have continuity
however when you're in a dream it also
has continuity you feel like let's say i
don't know let's say you dream you're a
professor well you didn't just appear
that day you feel like you were always a
professor in that dream
so to speak
hence
when we speak in small circles when when
logicians are in small circles and
they're talking they're like look how
can we tell how can we decipher from one
experience in the other the truth is we
cannot we only do it on sheer blind
faith this is a very important point
we only do it on sheer
blind animalistic
faith
that makes me remember this thing that i
refer to as a lucid moment
you know like when you're sleeping yeah
and then you're dreaming and then it's
like you realize like oh i'm sleeping
right i'm dreaming right now and then it
becomes like a lucid dream
or you just completely wake up out of
the dream
yeah but in real life like we have those
i don't know i can't speak for everyone
but i've had these like moments where i
realized like
i'm alive right now i'm actually
experiencing all of this and it's like
for that brief moment i become lucid
and um
there's a reason why i was gonna say
that disregard though
just completely left my heart
that was uh that was a mind bender bro
i think that's a high note to end this
one i have a quick question bro before
we end off uh the first dp it's from the
our editor for the clip channel he had
this question that he always wanted to
ask you if he had the opportunity so uh
he says salaam i have a question for
coach faraz zahabi uh if he mentions ibn
arabi or ibn sina because i've seen him
mention these people before please ask
since a lot of these scholars have done
took fear on these figures because of
the akita how would you differentiate
between their correct ideas and
incorrect ones when reading and do you
recommend them to lay viewers
no i wouldn't recommend delay viewers i
would say this okay i would say exactly
like hazard says it doesn't matter who
said what you have to bring every idea
and scrutinize it
and see if it's true or not after you
scrutinize it it doesn't matter who said
it it could be adolf hitler that said it
it could be the the best or the worst
person it doesn't matter divorce it from
who said it don't take it by authority
bring it here and let us examine it and
see if it's true if it stands on its own
merits
now there's a reason why he said that
because you know like for instance a lot
of muslims say don't use philosophy
philosophy is head up well let me ask
you this
what is philosophy what are you saying
that is haram when ghazali said when
ghazali said
when he wrote that
the destruction of the philosophers
he wasn't referring to philosophers
or logicians people using logic
he was referring to a group of muslims
who were blindly following aristotle
whatever aristotle says is true he was
referring to them as philosophers the
term has changed today philosopher
doesn't mean the same thing it meant in
the time of gazali
this is well highlighted in the works of
a frank griffel that we talked about
earlier
philosophy just means the study of logic
okay it literally means the
the love of wisdom to love wisdom
now are muslims not supposed to love
wisdom okay that's the literal meaning
but today if you go to university and
say i study philosophy well that means
you're going to study logic
it doesn't mean you're a lover of wisdom
okay that's what it literally means yes
but today it means oh you're going to
study epistemology you're going to study
analytical logic you're going to study
inductive logic you can study abductive
logic you're going to study oh how do we
know things
is that haram to study
logic
whoever says it's haram to study logic
has to give me a reason and when he
gives me a reason he's using logic
therefore he's
defeated his own position
it's a self-defeating position to say
it's haram to study logic
as a matter of fact if you read the
quran carefully
the kuffar the disbelievers are
criticized for not using logic
if they had used logic they would have
been believers this is the theme in the
quran like they're anybody to challenge
this anybody
i dare anybody to challenge me on this
point there are three over 300 verses
that refer to muslims to have to use
logic
reason is paramount now i'll tell you
something about reason reason is not
perfect
a master logician when he reaches the
highest levels of reason realizes that
he has to
at one point
realize that he can never know allah via
logic alone
he can know to a certain extent
logic can point to allah that's it a
logic can point to god
but the direct experience of god is a
gift
it's a gift
from god each one of us has a gift from
god why
we each have that fitrah we each reflect
the light of god
obviously we're not gods you know people
who say that in my opinion is the
epitome of arrogance
the islamic experience is to realize
you have the fitra
once you realize you have the fitrah you
have a direct experience with fitra ask
yourself did you know it logically no i
only knew it via direct experience
i always like to liken it to a robot you
know i always tell people okay imagine
robbie imagine we're gonna make a robot
rami 2.0
instead of skin we're going to use sheet
metal
instead of bones we're going to use
stainless steel instead of blood we're
going to put oil instead of a heart
we're going to put a pump
instead of eyes we're going to put a
camera instead of a brain we're going to
put a computer
and rami 2.0 he talks like you he walks
like you he thinks like you he he he
copies you every every little movement
he laughs at things that make you laugh
he cries at things that make you cry he
reacts identically to you
the only difference we see is when we
touch him he's
he's
steel
one day i come and i
destroy rami 2.0 i turn him into a
little box
did i murder him or did i damage
property
was he alive was he having the same
experience conscious experience as you
or was he only giving off the ex
experience the
the appearance of experience
rami 2.0 was only giving you you he was
only giving this
the appearance of consciousness like for
instance i always liken it to a ventric
ventriloquist doll
you know the doll sitting on a guy's lap
and the little kids watching him they
think that doll is alive
but really what they're doing is they're
projecting their mind this is a very
profound topic but they're projecting
their mind onto the doll
they don't realize that the doll has no
mind it's only projection of their mind
that doll
is just
a mechanical object
we can project our minds onto things
and we hence observe ourselves we think
we're observing a third party but really
we're observing our own mind
this is where the layman can't
differentiate
now if avecinia or even cena
said something that is
really haram let's say
you have to be very careful that you
understand number one their position
this is a resilient by the way and
nobody's gonna make fear of gazelli if
you make take fear of razali man you
should really learn your history
because he's the one agreed a pound guy
that nobody argued about in his time
no you know this hadith it says every
100 years there's going to be a reformer
in islam
nobody disagreed that it was ghazali
nobody finally one person in his time
that thought it wasn't ghazali
the leader of the muslim world find me
one guy you won't be able to find one we
had a unanimous consensus
over ghazali today people are
questioning because honestly they just
don't really understand what he's saying
number one you have to understand truly
what they're saying
if you don't say allahu allah i'm not
i'm not touching that you know i'm not
gonna say any opinion i don't understand
what he's trying to say now they did say
things they did some philosophers did
say things that i totally don't agree or
i don't understand what they meant
and razeli had three listen he had three
things that he criticized
um
[Music]
he'd been sina for three things he was
certain were
taking them taking him out of the fold
of islam three things he later dropped
one of those three things
so even the most you can never be so
sure you know what that person means
because later on
his followers were challenged on this
one point
and it had to do did the dunya always
exist or did it come into existence
if you read the quran very carefully
the quran never says that the dunya
the the entirety of the dunya came into
existence because there's there's again
i have no opinion on this because i'm
not experienced but the the throne of
allah is that dunya
there are topics there are nuances to
the topic that i'm not an expert in but
they went back and forth and this topic
later on the resilient followers
followers they dropped it and roselli
didn't comment on it anymore
so there seemed to be
so what i'm trying to say sometimes
we're not sure what that person meant
and second of all sometimes we don't
understand what that person meant and
third of all
um because he said one thing that's
wrong doesn't mean he said something
else that's wrong he could be correct
and what he said was wrong who knows
where his heart was that's between him
and allah
so i'm not going to judge him but what i
will do is i'll take every idea and
scrutinize it
and
i'll do that with every human being
because no human
being other than the prophets or outside
of being critiqued
because every human being could have a
faulty idea do you think hazeli never
made a mistake as much as i praised them
do you think he never was wrong about
anything of course he was wrong about
certain things do you think aristotle
was never wrong
he was a in his time he was a he was
probably the greatest thinker
do you think sir isaac newton was never
wrong he's arguably the greatest
scientific thinker in history
do you think einstein was never wrong of
course every human being was wrong about
something
so
is it just their limitations like let
my opinion let god judge them
let god judge them god will know if they
were had a had the intention to misguide
people or were there this is just the
faculties that allah gave them and this
is how the conclusion that they had at
the end it's going to come down to what
their intention was
and allah is going to judge them my
position is to take every idea and
scrutinize it i don't care who said this
idea i want to see if it's true does it
hold
on its own merits and this is what
ghazali tells us to do
so i don't see how any muslim could
argue against that
all right
if you all have anything to say without
me you can end this one off
um it's fun a lot man my mind is blown
too much philosophy
it's a good thing
i have nothing else to add man if you
want to go ahead no we waiting for mma
bro
yeah me too loki all right with that
being said
[Music]
all right so i think there's another
thing too it's it's the perseverance
aspect too like we're more willing to
stick through with things that we set
out with an intention it's impossible to
have empathy for others if you're not
patient so my love bless you for that
first of all i agree with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]